Some people learn the hard way – don't threaten
Batman with a good time.
Comic book aficionados know all too well to
keep their eyes extra peeled during a new
superhero movie.
From Marvel to DC, these films often contain
an assortment of Easter eggs and hidden references
designed to reward those who have kept up
with the characters' comic book roots.
Sometimes these references are thrown in just
for fun, while in other cases, they're designed
to hint at greater machinations at play.
"The Batman" certainly has no shortage of
Easter eggs.
Right from the very beginning, the very first
murder takes place on Halloween night.
It's hard to hear that without immediately
thinking of one of the best, most popular
Batman stories to ever grace the pages of
a comic book — "The Long Halloween."
The rest of the film may deviate from that
storyline, but the influences of that story
remain clear.
There's also the quick line Catwoman gives
toward the end of the film where she mentions
heading to Blüdhaven, which has great significance
to the lore of DC Comics.
Of course, not every Easter egg has to deal
with Batman himself.
We found one that seems like it's referencing
one of star Robert Pattinson's previous cinematic
outings.
Robert Pattinson has an extensive filmography.
While most general moviegoers may know him
for his role of Edward in the "Twilight" series,
he has a litany of independent projects that
prove he's a master at his craft.
Anyone who has seen him perform in "Cosmopolis,"
"High Life," or "The Lighthouse" was surely
ecstatic when the announcement came that he
would soon take on the role of Bruce Wayne.
However, there's a little-known movie Pattinson
starred in that's certainly worth your time,
especially seeing how it may have received
a shoutout in "The Batman."
2017's "Good Time" sees Pattinson play Connie
Nikas, a criminal on the run after a robbery
goes sideways.
It's an intense thriller from the Safdie Brothers,
who would go on to give the world a more high-profile
thriller with the Adam Sandler-starring "Uncut
Gems."
The film earned rave reviews from critics
and general audiences, according to Rotten
Tomatoes, so you should check it out if you
have the chance.
You can rent or purchase it on Amazon Prime
Video if you're interested in checking out
a great non-superhero movie that will still
get your blood pumping.
The movie also seemed to make an appearance
in "The Batman."
Early in the film, there's an establishing
shot of a market with an awning reading "Good
Times Grocery."
It's hard not to see that and not immediately
think of Pattinson's resume.
Of course, it could just be a coincidence,
but it's fun to think Matt Reeves wanted to
include a lesser-known Pattinson Easter egg
in his superhero flick.
Plenty of people may wonder why director Matt
Reeves would specifically want to give a shoutout
to "Good Time" as opposed to any other movie
in Pattinson's filmography.
As it turns out, "Good Time" played a significant
role in getting Pattinson the part of Bruce
Wayne in the first place.
In an interview with Esquire, Reeves mentioned
watching "Good Time" and immediately knew
Pattinson was his guy.
He elaborated,
"In the process of writing ["The Batman"],
I watched "Good Time," and I thought, 'Okay,
he's got an inner kind of rage that connects
with this character and a dangerousness, and
I can feel this desperation.'
And I became dead-set on it being Rob."
Reeves goes on to mention how he didn't even
know at the time if Pattinson would have any
interest in taking on the character, but he
so desperately wanted him to be his Bruce
Wayne.
As it turns out, Pattinson was more than game,
provided he could do a really dirty, slimy
version of the character.
As Pattinson stated in an interview with MovieMaker,
"At the time, even my agents thought it pretty
out of character to just suddenly get fixated
on Batman.
And I didn't even really know the status of
the project."
Both men got their wishes as Reeves was able
to cast Pattinson, and the actor indeed plays
a dirtier iteration of the Caped Crusader
in the film.
He went on to tell Premiere,
"[Batman] lives a criminal life, but without
committing crimes!
I felt like I could get something out of that.
Anyway, I could only play a superhero if he
was really dirty!"
Everything worked out for the best in the
end; turns out Pattinson had a good time as
Batman after all.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.